[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute geht es Carrot Cake Cupcakes also
eigentlich carrot Cupcakes
Cupcakes hat sich komisch an weil warum
soll ich jetzt Karottenkuchen Cupcakes
sagen wow es sind Karotten Cupcakes ganz
genau den Karottenkuchen gibt's bei mir
auf dem Kanal schon einige und Karotten
Cupcakes habe ich bisher noch nicht
gemacht ich mache jetzt hier einen
All-in-One Rührteig das bedeutet ihr
könnt die Zutaten abwägen direkt in eine
große Schüssel und dann einfach nur
verrühren ich zeige euch mal welche ich
wähle dafür verwende ich 70g gemahlene
Mandeln 150 g Zucker 200 g Mehl plus
Backpulver oder ihr nimmt mein backmehl
etwas Zimt Salz und Muskatnuss 200g
geraspelte Möhren etwas Vanilleextrakt
orangenpaste jeweils 150 g Buttermilch
und Sonnenblumenöl und zwei Eier also
jetzt ganz einfach alle Zutaten in die
Rührschüssel und schön miteinander
verrühren den Ofen habe ich auch schon
vorgeheizt das heißt es geht jetzt hier
alles richtig schnell
dann nehme ich jetzt hier einen großen
Eisportionierer und füllt den Teig
einfach in die Papierförmchen ein und
dann können die Muffins gebacken werden
und sobald sie gebacken sind werde ich
ein Frosting herstellen
[Musik]
die Cupcakes sind jetzt abgekühlt ich
zeige euch jetzt welche Creme ich
herstelle ihr könnt jetzt auch eine
Mascarpone Quark Creme machen oder eine
Frischkäsecreme ich finde hier passt so
ein traditionelles Frosting ganz gut
dazu für das Frosting verwende ich 150 g
weiche Butter etwas Vanilleextrakt und
jeweils 150 g Puderzucker und Frischkäse
und die Cupcakes stelle ich kurz zur
Seite
jetzt verrührt ihr zuerst die weiche
Butter mit Puderzucker und
Vanilleextrakt für etwa 4 bis 5 Minuten
cremig
[Musik]
okay jetzt ist die Masse weiß cremig und
dann kommt der Frischkäse dazu
wird kurz eingerührt und dann ist das
Frosting fertig und ich finde
tatsächlich dass dieses Frosting nicht
so buttrig schmeckt nicht sondern
Buttergeschmack hat aber für butterfans
trotzdem gut genug ist denn es ist
wirklich so eine Vanillecreme die
einfach gut schmeckt
zack
und jetzt guckt euch mal diese
Konsistenz an
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier die Creme in den
Spritzbeutel gefüllt mit einer großen
Lochtülle jetzt ist wichtig dass die
Cupcakes schon komplett abgekühlt sind
ich nehme jetzt aber trotzdem schon mal
raus
setz dich jetzt mal direkt hier auf eine
Platte damit ich höre arbeiten kann und
jetzt machen wir mal klassische Cupcakes
und später zeige ich euch noch was
cooles nein
und jetzt einfach den Spritzbeutel so
halten in der Mitte starten und dann
machen wir so eine schöne Haube da drauf
jetzt dekoriere ich die Cupcakes fertig
ich habe hier ein paar Mandeln etwas
Zartbitterschokolade und die crisperns
in Vollmilch die Mandeln hacke ich jetzt
einfach grob
ich finde es sind so klassische carrot
Cupcakes die könnt ihr natürlich
dekorieren wie ihr wollt aber ich mache
das jetzt Glas
und später probiere ich was aus
dann nehme ich hier die Cris und zwar
sind es mit Schokolade überzogene Keks
Kugeln richtig lecker
[Musik]
und fertig bis zum kalt stellen
ich habe jetzt hier einen Cupcake schon
ausgepackt und probiere den für euch ich
wollte ja eigentlich noch eine andere
Deko machen heute ich habe ja fast
versprochen ich mache noch eine
überraschungsdeko aber es ist jetzt zu
spät
hey mach einfach irgendwann in einem
anderen Video mache ich das was ich euch
zeigen wollte denn ich glaube was ich
zeigen wollte ist auch ziemlich cool
aber ich muss halt auch sagen ich finde
die so wie sie jetzt sind halt auch echt
schön
deswegen war die Motivation dann weg
noch eine zweite Deko zu machen weil die
so an sich schon sehr schön sind
außerdem hat ein Freund von uns
Geburtstag und ich würde ihm jetzt sechs
Stück verpacken und dann mit so einem
Happy Birthday drauf und dann richtig
schön die andere Deko das zeige ich euch
mal wann anders okay wir probieren mal
guck mal hier ich finde ja dass Carrot
Cake im Inneren einfach immer so mega
gut aussieht weil er so eine schöne
Farbe hat und einfach mega saftig ist
also probieren jetzt mal
[Musik]
gesagt
mega schöne Farbe
richtig gut
auf ansonsten finde ich das Caritas
Cupcakes oder Karottenkuchen an sich
sowieso in Rezepte fürs ganze Jahr und
schreibt mir gerne was ihr euch wünscht
also macht's gut bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]